Hello everybody, hello, hello.
I'm sorry for pushing that stream.
Today, I was so tired post Daft Punk concert.
Like I had a, I had like an energy crash right after, you know.
Because not Daft, I was right, I was tired before.
The event and I used up all my energy during the event that was like actual like Like force shut down Like I was like zero percent battery and I like took a nap and I was when I woke up when I woke up from my time I was like
Yeah, I used up all the reserve and energy I had like my the post death bump clarity I was just like I'm like 30 more minutes like um five more minutes mom and mom is also me and I'm like no Doki you have to get up Doki you gotta stream like five more minutes I felt like I was that's a real concert the concert hang Um,
but they have to go to work like literally the same day See this is why I'm like why it was why did they have that the concert of morning
The mom voice in my head like this is why because I still because we still have to go to work after The rain was too good.
Oh Frenchmen!
Anyway, today we're going to be finishing sleeping dogs today.
Apparently there is only a few missions left.
So we are going to try and complete the game today.
I can't believe it's been...
Well, I can't believe we're at the final part already.
I thought...
I don't know.
I did play a lot.
I did play a lot already.
but like the game the game i don't know if the game is really good that like it doesn't feel like i've been playing for a while because like everything just links together so well so um so it doesn't feel like i'm doing a lot of missions but i have been playing sleeping dogs for a bit already all right let's go i was so happy with the daft punk concert though it was honestly i went in the expectations I went in with for the game were already sort of high but not really.
Okay, so it was originally high, the expectations for it, but there was like leaked document, like leaked summary info and leaked file, like people were leaking the files and stuff being like, oh, we're like data mining and it doesn't seem like there's any of the older songs,
it's just like the newer stuff they did, like get lucky and stuff like that.
and and they're like they didn't like they did disclaimer there was a blog summary of the event itself and the disclaimer was like oh that punk is not really getting back together and then they were like oh um this is not a concert it's an experience and i was like oh wait if it's not a concert then what the fuck are we getting like so i was like so my expectations are getting
my god i'm so happy that like um the data mining was like not right not true and um and like i don't know why the fuck they said it wasn't a concert like that shit that was a concert like they gave they recreated a live 2007 why the fuck did they say it wasn't a concert yet uh i haven't done the game yet there you go here's the game i had such a good time It was definitely a really,
yeah, it was a fault, they spread false information to like set me up, to set, give me like low expectations, and then it exceeded everything I've ever wanted in a Daft Punk concert in Fortnite.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat, thank you for the magenta soup, thank you, thank you.
Congrats on your first Daft Punk concert, Doki, so glad you could experience it live with us, and find a great stream for me while I was working.
concert while on the clock thank you for the magenta super thank you thank you yeah i'm glad they under promised that because um i i like i like i just didn't know what to expect and it was it was definitely a great experience in the end um i'm just happy i'm just happy we get i'm happy we get something from that you know there was like 1.2 million people um watching that concert like in fortnite that was just like in fortnite experiencing the concert like live was 1.2 million people and those were like not people just watching it like from other other streamers it was just it was just in fortnite itself in that game mode yeah i thought that was fucking and that's like how much like that's why that punk is such a universally beloved music group and like everyone was like i just love how fortnite has made like so many new fans for daft punk even though they've retired and they're not making any more new music um they're still so beloved today like they're not they're not doing any tour
anymore they don't even before they retired we only got two tours before they retired
like I was so sad we only got two and yeah I do hope to get even more recognition than they already have and just to show them like they're so beloved to this day and like everyone still remembers them and maybe maybe we'll have a reunion concert in 2027 maybe just maybe
but um i i just thought that you know um it really did the show to like death punk like you know they're so loved we all so missed them and like you know maybe please come back we can please we can we can rebuild you we can rebuild them i please and i i don't i swear to god if they do appearance because the only times they do guest appearances is like when it's like at like some fucking Hollywood event that like only celebrities are invited to and you know so I'm like please please just please I just want I don't care how much I have to pay I just would I just would have watched you live I don't want to see you on TV
And it's like they do one song too.
They do, it's like, they don't even like let you know that they're going to be there.
It's always a surprise appearance too.
They don't even know.
It's like, they're like, oh, surprise.
Like right there, live.
That bug's here.
And they're like, what?
And then you find out on Twitter.
You have to find out on Twitter that they were in this random concert appearance.
for two minutes before they disappear again.
I have to get FOMO'd.
But yeah, I'm just happy.
I'm just happy that Fortnite did this.
Like, we haven't had new Fortnite.
Oh, no, not Fortnite.
We haven't had new Daft Punk content in so long.
So, like, I'll take anything I can get, you know.
They'll throw some scraps on the floor, and then they're like, eat it.
And I'm like, oh, you're so kind to me, death, monk.
Thank you, sir.
And I'll just be on the floor, be like, oh, thank you.
They can step on the food too, and I'll be like, thank you for feeding me just a little bit.
Oh, my thank you.
You're so kind to feed me.
I've been starving for so long.
thank you thank you for the little crumbs and they're like all right well all right you'll be fed in another 10 years i'm like oh you're so kind thank you for thinking of me thank you for for feeding me again in 10 years you're so kind you're that's my that's my oh she oh my what did i do to deserve such a kind.
It's such a such a kind like a such a kind master.
Thank you so much for feeding me, even if it's in 10 years.
Josh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
They give so much to us, guys.
They give so much to us.
That's how that's how much I love depth I don't care at this point like any even the tiny crumb and I'll be satisfied they died like four to five years ago I'm like it's okay
they them gracing us with their presence is good enough for me like I see them for one second and I'm like I'm happy at least I know they're alive I see them for one second I'm like, oh, thank God they're alive.
So, they're still there.
All right, let's grab our favorite card.
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Chat really reflects the streamer, huh?
So, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope somebody uploads it in VR chat.
I feel like it looks...
Okay, if they ever upload it in VR, chat.
I'm fucking playing it in VR.
I'm gonna go in there as Kroki and be like, yeah!
I hope someone uploads it in VR chat.
Yeah, I feel like in VR, it's gonna be even wilder.
Yeah, the way I'm... This is my post-concert.
My post-concert run right now.
Okay, wait.
Oh my god, wait.
Hello.
I just came back from a Daft Punk it and i need to be extra relaxed you looking for a massage yes i give you the special treatment how can i say i'm gonna be like all
right here we go you know i'm gonna celebrate you're right
that's right you see that you heard it this is my celebratory post staff punk
massage.
Wait, what?
Did I make all the stuff?
I don't care about that.
I'm here for the funeral.
Where the fuck is the funeral?
Oh, there it is.
The funeral is more important.
I got lucky tonight.
That's right.
Up all night to get lucky.
I'm up all night.
Some.
I'm up all night to get some.
I'm up all night.
Fun.
I'm up all night to get lucky.
I was trying to remember the driving controls.
Okay, let me turn on the alarm real quick so they'll know.
Get out of here.
I have important business to do at my business factory, at my adult factory.
All right, here we go.
Yeah!
The law stops for no one.
You think you're special?
You're not special.
Oh shit, not you.
I can't.
Sorry.
I'll never hurt you.
Porkbun.
Porkbun, man.
There we go.
One last ride before we go.
Yay!
Wait, it's so far.
Where the fuck is this place?
Okay, oh, Jiamsan.
Wait, is that Jiamsan Zhang?
Oh, Jiamsan Shang.
Okay, they try.
I think there's no... Wait, is there, like, actual, like, like, location?
in hong kong here because i'm like oh my god wait is that simsa jay but it's simsa shang
all right get out of here that's right nobody bikes in my streets it's very dangerous guys i didn't see wait is he wearing a helmet you're not wearing a helmet oh wait
lesson remember to wear your helmet guys and be safe okay wait give me a sec all right look i'm trying to teach you guys a very important lesson to always be safe see she didn't wear a helmet so it's something so bad things could happen to you there you go remember to wear your helmet guys remember to practice safe safety laws See,
it's very educational.
Although I'm here for the funeral.
See, if you didn't wear a helmet, this could happen to you.
Thanks for picking me up.
You joking?
Of course I'm gonna pick you up.
You're my boy.
If she had a helmet on, this wouldn't, she wouldn't have died.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I got lucky.
Someone convinced Ming's brother to say it was alone.
Was that you?
That's me.
I don't worry bro.
Tang something or another.
Huh?
Fuck herself.
Smooth.
You heard about Uncle Pogo, right?
Yeah.
When's the funeral?
Like today?
I thought you'd be like, oh it's today.
That'll be wild.
Like, hi, I bailed you out.
Anyway, get ready for a funeral.
Let's go.
Oh, we were taking my...
Oh, wait.
another gonna make me oh wait we are i all right let's go don't worry this is like um i decaled it myself you know it's not an actual cop car don't worry it's it's my itasha print i love i hate the police so much that i had to get my car wrapped in wrapped around she wanted to help me turn my started snitching,
she'd help me out.
Anyways, man, forget that bitch.
Alright, here we go.
We're here.
Oh, I pick up suits?
You don't own a suit, way?
Yeah, it's the perfect disguise, too.
Oh my god, you're so right.
I got rumored to be a whole man.
I'll take some, thanks.
Yeah, but I drive the police car ironically.
Alright, here we go.
I'll get you fitted You're very I'm already dressed in black these are the latest perfect for you for me
Elegant but not too flashy.
Oh nice, you know never thought I'd be able to afford a suit from a place like that Sucks that I have to get it for uncle post funeral Oh looking nice, bro.
All right, let's go So they don't know that we're actually criminals That's why I brought a police car.
It's the best undercover The best undercover vehicle for the job I'm so deep into how to cover I'm pretending to be a I'm a cop pretending to be a thug to be a cop and pretending to be a cop I bet it was the 18k You gotta make those assholes pay the fine The perfect stealth mission a triple agent
Was he in there for like a week?
I mean, it's not like I'm cut out to do anything else, but sitting in there, shit.
Now we're going to a funeral.
Who's the future in this shit?
You know what I mean?
I do.
All right, keep going.
Sorry, we just had, we had a little, uh, there was a paha.
Just a little paha.
Do you make?
Oh, shit!
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
Am I?
All that talk about being a big deal was just...
What?
That was a speed bump.
Yeah.
Right.
There's so many piles.
I know, right?
It's crazy.
Whoa!
Yeah, I'm Tropic Thunder.
Flames.
Never go full cop.
Alright,
thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, sir.
Do you play Hadoop Disguise as another dude?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright, this way.
How far is it?
Okay, it's that, it's pretty far.
Wow!
I look how they set up the ring too.
They're like extra...
They set up the ring.
The moon and everything.
Oh, these were the people that killed them.
What the fuck are the 18K doing?
Yeah.
We're here to make a show.
Or maybe to start a fight.
I want people to know that they did it.
I hear in one place.
I don't think they expected the police to be here, though.
I've been happy to see the cops before.
Hey.
Why are the cops here?
Huh?
They're fucking arresting him.
Sonny woke.
I've been looking forward to this moment for a long time.
Yes.
And it will make you look so good to your bosses.
They might even pat you on the head like an obedient dog.
Right up until the time that I walk.
Again.
Not this time, Sonny.
Come on.
Oh, so they can place their own guy into the position of power.
We got what we came for.
We're leaving.
Jesus, on funeral day?
You can't do this here.
It's a fucking funeral.
God damn, police.
Why don't you show some fucking respect, huh?
Why don't you?
The 18K are about to do this city a great public service.
And anyone who stays here deserves everything they get.
Wait, what?
He's working for the 18K?
The cops are leaving?
What the fuck?
The 18K are going to- This is going to get bloody.
Come on.
What?
The double cross?
I told these motherfuckers what it means to me, son of a damn way.
Good acting.
No, they'll never expect you to be a cop.
Oh my god, they give you this shitty gun too.
Oh my god, where are our bodyguards?
You would assume the...
The fucking...
T-M-E would have fucking bodyguards!
If we're...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I need to check.
Nope, that's all the leaders.
That's all of us.
Okay, that's...
Oh, we're so fucking stupid.
I assume because we are all like, you know, triad leaders, we would all...
Okay, let's...
I need to grab X-Fight.
Cover me.
me i'm grabbing extra hp don't worry you would assume wait where's the girl where's the woman where's the old lady isn't she gonna use her gun too okay there's no way i am the only bodyguard
okay rb wait i want to swap rb okay oh shit
I forgot we moved up.
I forgot those people.
He just got out of jail, bro.
Friendly fire.
Bro, he literally just got out of jail.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm getting...
Jesus Christ, I'm getting gunned down hard.
Oh, my God, my cover.
Out of jail into the year.
I'm just preparing him you know preparing him for the real world oh my god all my oh my god they got all our cover it's okay I still have this nice last guy all right pass that oh wait last guys to my left where the fuck is the last guy oh there he is where I'm gonna flank him Don't worry guys
Got you Follow the river TV.
Where's the river?
Oh, here
Oh wait
Okay, I was trying to like I was trying to grab him, but it wouldn't let me because I have a gun Wait, where's the grenade launcher?
Where did he...
Yeah, I was just looping him.
Wait, give me a sec.
I'm grabbing the grenade launcher.
Where the fuck did the grenade launcher go?
It's not fair!
I shot him in the kidneys.
There we go.
Anyway, I'll trip these guys.
That's right.
Oh, no more ammo.
Oops.
Give me a sec.
Grab this gun.
All right.
One more bullet to finish the job.
It disappeared with his soul.
I want to be surprised if I glitched down.
Eliminate the 18K in the parking lot.
What's this?
A tactical rifle?
Is it better?
Oh, it is.
That's tactical in the front.
That's when you know it's better.
Oh, hey, nice.
All right, let me through.
Oh!
We don't use hands here.
We kick our cover out.
All right, nice.
Where are the others?
Wait, what?
Did he call me?
Oh my god, okay.
One of the insults they said was, see, fuck, white.
Which means...
ass ghost.
He's like, you're an ass ghost.
And I'm like, what?
What did he call me?
Did he just call me an ass ghost?
He's like, keep on quiet.
Jesus, how many men are there?
Bro, thank god we're at a funeral parlor.
Thank god we're at a cemetery.
These guys are gonna get rich from us.
Alright, we have some new customers for you.
This is supposed to be good day for the funeral people look we can't let this go on we have to deal with 18k and with the police all right we need a plan where's truchin he's in seclusion seclusion he's in a hotel somewhere riding the white tiger that fat fuck perhaps you are right brother lee with uncle po gone we now need yeah we got him the group funeral bundle making some sense chuck i am the strongest i the most feared I say I should be chairman oh perhaps temporarily we should go wait we need to have a proper election that is the way it has always been done we're getting shot at right now you a woman talking of whoa whoa my contribution to this organization have been significant with respect oh damn swimming that means clear thinking we should follow our tradition our tradition you've only been on sun on you for a short time what do you know about that's true i have been here for like less than a month jang and brother shen are correct fine it's time to cancel him but i'm warning
you here and now making anyone other than me the chairman will be disastrous for sun on you everyone has a vote He's not really, like, doing very well for his campaign right now.
Ricky, don't.
I like how they politely said, like, oh, it means let's go.
But he was there to be like, Ricky, leave!
He was to say, like, let's go.
He's like, leave.
Yeah, I'm like, bro, you're not really selling yourself right now.
It doesn't make you want to vote for it.
they get jesus
yeah but context wise it's like leave go he's like let's go is like oh he's like something big is going now meet us in north point as soon as possible but that'd be that bad right i just came back from a funeral shooting what can be worse than what I just went through.
Let me...
Alright.
Oh, the PTSD is hitting hard right now.
I always have to be tactically prepared, guys.
I saw I gotta sleep in this.
It stays on.
I always gotta be prepared.
No, he definitely...
No, Wade definitely needs a lot of therapy.
but now what i'm saying is like that guy is like you guys better vote for me and i don't know if he just makes me like sort of makes me like not want to vote for him for some reason not a very good campaign speech
like i don't know doesn't feel like an election at that point
all right I gotta go to Wait, what is this machine called?
Civil Discord.
Oh, oh, we're gonna have a Discord meeting?
Let's go.
Alright, how far is A thousand meters?
Why can't they have this meeting closer to where I live?
Also, wait, actually.
Okay, why the fuck did I not wake up here?
Like, my home is...
My first home is closer to this Why did...
If I knew my meeting was going to be back in my old town, I would sleep there.
I should have taken a taxi.
You're right.
I didn't know it was that far.
Maybe I'll find it.
I can't...
There's no taxis anywhere.
It's raining, so all the taxis are being used right now.
You know how, like, if there's, like, um...
If there's bad weather, like, the Uber slash taxi prices go up because, like, they're so in demand.
everything i hate it when that happens i hate that when it takes like like 20 minutes to find an uber because it's raining or some oh did you guys hear um because there's like new fees um for uber uh a lot of people don't want to uber drive anymore because it's just not worth it so people are like doing their own self-driving service like uh what's it called They're doing,
uh, what is it called when you're doing, you're like on call?
What is it called again?
I know the mission's right here, but I'm trying to think of what it's called.
You know, when you just call someone up and they'll arrive?
No, it's not a ride share.
Like, you don't even use any self-employed.
No, but like, they're like, they're like contractors.
Yeah, yeah, no, they're like, it's like, they're like, oh, Like, you know, they'll have, like, regulars and stuff.
What the fuck?
Why am I beating them up?
Asshole!
You, me already, though.
This doesn't concern you.
Keep it here.
Don't be with the harbour when you're done.
Yeah, freelancing.
They're... What the fuck?
I thought I was, like...
Heading to a meeting.
What is this?
Why am I defeating an enemy triad?
Am I not heading towards...
I thought I was, like...
Oh my.
Yeah.
they're like oh my god is that grill oh wait that's a table wait let me say here's your orders oh wait that's a song that's a song that's hardcore bro i thought it was just a table all right oops okay guys it's okay he didn't die i never commit murder i'm a cop okay all right i need it oh my god look all these environments.
Get back here.
Get back in here.
I'm not done with you.
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe I'm done with this particular guy.
Get back here.
I'm not done with you.
Oh shit.
Nice.
It looks like...
Oh.
Come on.
Get...
No!
Get back in here!
It looks like you might need an oil change.
Oh, shit!
Okay, I don't expect some of the stuff I'm doing.
Alright, what's this?
Don't worry, we're...
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, looks like we're heading into a pit stop!
Oh, that's a Kirit.
Alright.
Don't worry, we'll get there soon.
Oh, it's trash day!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, you're scared?
Yeah, you're scared?
Oh, let's get him, get the knife out of him.
Oh, okay, we gotta get out.
Get out of here!
That's fucking right!
That's, that's it.
Give me your knife.
That's it, I need your knife.
Oh, what?
Bro, I want his knife!
Holy shit, there's so many guys.
There's too many!
Too many cooks!
Okay.
Jesus, there's not enough environmental kills to kill all of them.
too many guys oh i can't get over that that shit is crazy all right there's one more i haven't seen yet oh don't leave the chop shop don't worry i won't leave i just need to use that one one last environmental kill oh i'm so sad you want to give me his knife oh there you go never mind okay let's get this over with
Let's just start shaking.
There's too many.
There's too many guys and not enough one-liners.
Oh shit, I got you.
I got you.
Looks like we have a power outage.
All right, get over here.
Come on, get over here.
Bro, I'm trying to... Did you order a Pepsi?
All right, now we can kill him.
He had a painful death.
God, he's so tanky.
It's all that.
He's so big bone right now.
Pepsi, man.
Jesus.
I'm trying not to leave.
Did Dragon be out here?
Has he been fighting one guy this entire time?
I had to fight a fucking army.
That's crazy.
My bro has been fighting one person this entire time.
And I took down this entire army.
God, get out of my way!
Get kicked.
That's it.
I'm not having fun anymore fighting you.
You're next.
Bro, I'm trying to get him out of...
there we go get out of here all right I did it you think it's over not yet I'm not playing around anymore you better take them thanks you better lay low that's it all for one gun wait what's going on man shit they're mrs. choose they're coming after everything we got what these fucks think they are.
Big smiley's coming after us.
I guess he figures we can't vote against the people dead.
You see, Pepsi is bad for you.
One out?
No, I'm with you all the way, boss.
We're with you, Wayne.
Just for once.
I'd like to fight someone outside my own triad, though.
Mama, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Lonnie, thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Guy gets a table saw, two guys get crushed, one electric grid, then one just gets a dumpster, and another a Pepsi.
Thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
definitely need a massage after this.
Oh man, I got the worst guns here.
The spread is too...
too big for this.
Okay, nice.
The NPCs are actually...
The AI is actually helping me.
Alright, we gotta swap guns though.
I hate this gun so much.
Okay, get inside the golden coin.
Oh, we got... we gotta save Mrs. Chill!
Oh, this is a nice restaurant.
They're in the market.
Coming from the market.
No, not the market.
Oh, my God.
I got a shotgun.
Okay, I got...
Whoa!
Where did I go?
You know what?
They're like, you gotta be closer.
We'll help you.
The game was like, don't worry.
We'll help you get closer.
Oh, shit!
I'm a...
Instant transmission.
Okay, maybe it's definitely not a good idea to stand behind a car.
I could tank a little, a bit of this.
Reloading!
Okay, there we go.
Now I got the gun I want.
Oh my god, it's the same gun.
It's the same gun.
fire yet so we're fine jesus where are you shooting me oh my god okay i don't know how i'm alive i hate oh my god oh my god you you mean to tell me i had a gun right here this entire time okay there you go now it's a lot easier
i can't believe there was a gun in front of me this entire time
see how much easier this
I always forget which one's jaw, which one's Yao.
I always get confused between left and right and cat in me.
I don't know, it's just not intuitive for me.
I was like, which one is Yao?
Which one is Yao?
We're just a noodle restaurant.
Why the fuck is everyone shooting at us?
We don't have, oh my god.
We don't have nothing here.
Do you really think we make it enough?
There you go.
We are not that profitable.
You're kind of...
Whoa, Mrs. Chu, what's going on?
I'll go check it out.
You stupid bitch?
What?
Where's Wyshen?
I got a message for him from Big Smile Lee.
Just a piece of shit I'm looking for.
You're going to vote for Lee, you hear me?
They really want that recipe.
Fuck you all your ancestors Oh shit guys We got a new special at the noodle shop guys Whoa Damn The meat sure does taste extra Grainy today Is that a ring in my Is that hair in my Yeah Don't mess with mama exactly The car survives I'm just gonna blow up this car.
Fuck it.
I think that's just easier.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
They're right behind me.
Don't worry.
Okay, I ran out of gun.
Oh, wait.
No, I saw one more bullet.
There you go.
Don't worry.
Oh, shit.
Fuck it.
All right, nice.
Parkour.
Don't worry.
I'm really good at parkour.
Get a load of this.
What's that?
Is that grenade on tree?
Holy fuck.
The toggle between grenades and bullets.
Okay, I assume that's grenade.
Oh my god.
Just a regular day in Hong Kong.
Hong Kong, guys.
Just the usual.
No coffee called or anything.
Just your daily territory wars, you know?
Daily turf wars in the streets of Hong Kong.
Actually, I'll just build this car.
That's just easier.
For that one guy, too.
Let's Grab the bullets.
Oh my god, that guy's just running straight in.
He's crazy.
Oh my god, they're so far.
Oh, there, nice.
Wait, there's more?
Where are they?
Oh my god, they're all the way over there.
They were all the way over there.
You mean they were on the balcony.
They're like, wait, they're all over there.
I'm like, where?
You mean the ones that just died?
Oh,
well, that's awkward.
I let a lot of them die.
Are you done?
Day one, massage, day 10, gang war.
Oh, my God.
Oh, now they're here right after I've killed all of them.
That's crazy.
They're so good at their jobs.
Ever since I went undercover, the cops just haven't been the same, man.
I was literally carrying 80% of their job.
But you know what?
What if I just...
I forgot I can just kill them.
Okay, but what about the other guys?
They might be dead, but you can still arrest them, posthumously.
That's it.
I'm angry.
Get over here, boom!
Oh, shit.
That's right.
They really want some low opinion.
They heard Mrs. Chu was doing a one-time offer on the noodles.
And that's...
It's like, there's only 10 foes left, and then she'll never serve them again.
The noodles are serious business.
I like how they're like, lose them, and I was like, I'm just like, technically I'm losing them if they're dead.
They can't catch me if they're dead, technically, if you think about it.
I did it, guys.
I lost them, because they lost their lives.
Where the hell is Jackie?
I don't know.
I haven't seen them.
Call them.
They're not right.
No witnesses.
They didn't specify how to lose them.
Wow, where did they go?
I don't know.
You think they might have gone after it?
They went to Mrs. Chu.
Fuckers are going after everyone.
Good.
Thank God the police don't care about these random barrels.
Lots of fresh meat tonight, boys!
That's true.
Mrs. Chu now has a lot of...
a lot of supplies now.
Just a lot of ingredients for her...
for a restaurant.
She's gonna have to do grocery shopping along.
For a long time.
Because meat's back on the menu.
Alright.
This is some new stuff.
Oops.
Okay, I still have a... I still have one more badge left.
I'm still keeping my badge.
What's the worst they can do is suspend me with a badge?
pay they don't fire cops we have to talk i got nothing to say to you calm down hey listen big smiley's coming after anyone who's why is he mad at me i work for sunny whoa we're lee's biggest backers and unlike you i'm loyal to my friends sunny told me about you and vivian what what ricky i didn't do anything i swear it bro i turned down video of us together what mail me and now the police have it they're threatening to release it if I don't testify against sunny what do you think Lee will do to her when he hears or you said no of all the people sunny told me to be with way is the only one who said no wait I'm the only way how many guys were you with why are you not pissed at those guys and pissed at me if you back sunny Lee will probably ask you to kill her yourself or you can get her out of here keep her safe and sunny stays in jail wait what the fuck no no she's been with so many other men and you're mad at me why are you not mad at her to be fair she's like forced into the situation
but like like it's not her fault to be fair but like why is he mad at me
she like she's so like i said no and even then i'm not the only one to like like have her sent over oh good boy like she's been hooking up with so many people for sunny hey why is he saying fuck me for it he needs to be mad at someone
all right nice thank god the cab will take me here
Are you okay, sir?
Yeah,
she's like Sonny's, like, go-to, like, she's, like, the Uber ride.
That Sonny sends over.
Oh, I'm on the, wait, I'm on the boat now.
You got a lot of nerve after that ship Pendrew pulled at the funeral.
What, he sent you to finish the job?
Pedro doesn't know I'm here, right?
I'm completely violating protocol.
Look, I never wanted you for this job because I'm what dog eyes did to your sister and how you handle things in San Francisco What did I do in San Francisco?
Anyone could have expected.
I can only imagine the pressure you must have been under Don't get sappy on me now Raymond wait you cross-pendrew He's cut you off.
What is your last chance to come in clean?
How did I cross-pendrew?
What is he gonna do arrest me?
Call me a rogue cop?
Look how do I gave him everything he wanted is he gonna blow my cock I don't know what he'll do Not anymore Wait, just come back with me now You're a good man We can fix this, smooth it over with Pendry
Jackie, not now I'm busy Mr. Shen We have your friend Receive our instructions Follow them if you want to Wait, they took Jackie Look, it's Jackie, I need to go Wait, wait Bro, he just got out of prison Bro, he's been there so much Why did I take him?
Take Jackie.
Come to the Aberdeen Dryad.
Come alone and unarmed.
Say I'm allowed to take a taxi.
They're like, come alone.
Can you send me the address so I can, like, send it to the Uber driver?
Can you?
Can you Google Maps me the address real quick?
Wait, where's the tax?
Oh, it's because it's raining.
All the taxis.
Oh, wait, no.
There's one taxi.
Oh, the light's up.
Look.
The light is up on top, which means the taxi is unoccupied.
Okay, never mind.
I'm not allowed to take a taxi, apparently.
God damn it.
I don't care if I'm not allowed to take a taxi.
I'll bring this cab no matter what.
Can you pay for my Uber, bro?
I don't care.
A taxi's coming with me, whether you like it or not.
Oh yeah, but anyway, going back to my story about Uber drivers, but a lot of, apparently, um, Uber drive, damn, bro, that's hardcore.
This taxi driver was listening to this song.
Um, a lot of Uber drivers now are freelancing.
So they get like, uh, so they get like a consistent, you know, the ones that like, you know, the crazy people that actually talk to their Uber drivers, and then to get to know them, they like, get their numbers and stuff and be like, hey, I don't work at Uber anymore.
And more like cheaper deals on getting a ride to your place.
Like, you know, They always commute to places with Uber.
You can, like, hit me up and stop paying for...
Paying Uber.
I'll get down there.
He, like, looked down there, but I can't open the door.
Oh, you're standing next to the door.
I can't go in.
What?
Or do me down the alleyway.
Oh my god, it's down the alleyway.
I was just like, what the fuck?
Wait, no.
Where?
No, it tells me to go back.
Which is the right door?
Is it the one with the red light?
Why is he opening the door for me?
Sir.
I like walked back and then it like told me like, that's not the way.
Green is over here.
here yeah but when I went down here look the greens there look see what the oh my god this is confusing I assume it's down here but why is the green trail still like coming out of my ass oh it is here what the fuck oh shit maybe I'm as dumb told me to come over here with no one you would have killed jackie that came over here with reinforcements anyway i gotta do my daily prayer that's
it i don't think i'm a i can like oh shit wait oh wait there's a trash can you know what that means oh my god there's a bus stop
all right get over here hey you want to play some among us real quick Because it looks like...
It looks like you're sus!
Okay, let's grab you in here.
Looks like you belong in the trash!
I think that's everything.
That's all of it.
They only gave me two.
Oh, wait!
I don't even know what to say.
This shit is fucked up, bro.
This one's a little fucked up.
I don't even know what to say for this.
Oh my god, there's the pyrograde.
Looks like we're going to have a power outage today.
Are you ready for your schedule power outage?
I wonder if I could use this table.
Oh, that's it.
It's okay.
You know what I do have, though?
The trusty wall.
Oh my god, wait, he's still alive?
Bro, your head, you're bleeding from your head right now, bro.
back up get back up i was gonna say bro you're bleeding from your head go sit down or get all right oh my god get over here i'm not done with you or i'm not done with you or get don't want he's
like i'm so scared
he's like oh my god don't hurt me And so I was like, time to break the fourth wall!
Alright, last guy.
I'm so sad I can't grapple the grappler.
That's right, get out of here.
Oh man, he's like, this is personal now.
He's like, that's it, I'll settle this myself.
Oh yeah?
Watch this.
Say hello.
Yeah, you trying to do a kick?
Nutshot.
Say hello to my little friend.
Oh, you think it's over?
It's rewind time.
Oh, you think it's over still?
Looks like I'm doing a little redecorating.
I think this shade, this red, would go nicely on the wall.
You're just another break in the wall!
One more time.
Grab horse face.
Who the fuck is horse?
Oh, that's him.
Oh.
Where's Jackie?
You're never going to find him.
Oh, yeah?
That's right.
Tell me where he is now.
Okay.
Oh, do I interrogate him here?
Oh, shit.
Stop.
Where's Jackie?
I don't know.
You don't know.
I was just supposed to kill you.
I don't know.
Bro, I just wanted to kill you, bro.
Come on.
How do I get to him?
I don't know.
You tell me, and I might...
Where is he?
I only talk to him on my phone.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
I was like, wait, is the line looping?
Go back up the street to get...
A better signal.
It's not a big deal, Teehee.
I just wanted to kill you.
Hehehe.
Is it really that bad?
In my car?
Bro, no!
My taxi!
I was about to pay off the load!
Oh goodness, I was two payments away!
Hello?
this where's horse face this is new shoes i work for horse face i'm not talking to you on your boss on he's dead shen killed him what shen killed him landed in work what what plan oh here it is i don't know anything about tracing complete and then i just hang up on him it's like what the fuck i feel like it's more suspicious when i hang up on him too hong kong police get over here get out This is important police,
police business.
I am way policeman.
What is this way?
Lisa, I think it is.
Super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Wait, I have an SUV.
You say I'm fast enough?
That bot.
Got a faster car.
Oh, wait, there it is.
Okay, yeah, I was not gonna...
I was not gonna reach them.
At least he dropped his cell phone, right?
Wait, where is his cell phone?
Wait, where did he drop his cell phone?
Is it the bike?
Where the fuck did he drop the cell phone?
Wait, did he...
through the floor?
Are you
kidding me?
He like fell.
The boy it has him now.
The boy it has him.
Oh my god.
Bro, that's his bike.
I was like, where did he go?
I think I think he phased through.
It's in the wall.
Alright, we're gonna have to Oh my god We're gonna have to restart From checkpoint, yes Please not be that far Oh, there he is Where am I Wait, did he have a heart attack?
Wait, did he...
He had a fucking heart attack or something Where the fuck am I?
He got on the bike and he just again collapsed.
He got death noted.
Oh, there it goes.
Sliding.
And he's slipping away.
He's escaping quick, Doki.
Grab him.
He broke the game because he was too good.
Josh, the human is super.
Does he slide near this?
Oh.
And now the bush has him.
He has returned to nature, everyone.
He has returned to nature.
Will he face through here?
Oh, it's stopped.
Oh, it's because he can't go through.
He's back to the nature.
Let's go.
Nature has reclaimed his body.
Okay, I don't want to fuck around.
salty crab in Kennetown.
I was so confused.
I was like...
I was like, what the fuck happened?
Why couldn't I?
Where did his body go?
That was the easiest chase ever.
Thank God.
The game was like, she's on an SUV.
We gotta give her a bone.
Like...
There was no way she was gonna catch up.
We gotta do something It's skipped and then I guess we'll never know we'll never oh my god I would steal this car the cop wasn't there
I guess we'll never know I have I pulled a hard pity
Not oh my god that's a sick ass car get out it's my car
That's right get out the police needs this car No, taxis don't work when you're on a mission.
Holy shit.
This is very, very important police business.
Don't worry.
You'll definitely get your car back.
Holy shit, this is a fast-ass car.
Police business!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was sick.
That was sick as fuck.
Oh my god, I went through in the...
I make my own door, my own entry, my own exit.
Sick jump worth it.
Gun is an evoke as requested.
I do it a lot of ammo to him.
Thanks.
You want to travel and companion?
Thanks, but this is personal.
Now this is a cop movie.
That's why you wear a seatbelt, everyone.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, they're right behind me, aren't they?
Don't worry, I'm a good driver.
Oh my god, we're at the end game now.
Now this is a police movie.
Now this is a Hong Kong police movie.
Another day for the cops.
Escape the ambush?
okay this wasn't much of an ambush if that's it
how how many oh my god okay at this point I don't know what can kill you okay I was gonna be like how are you alive
I don't understand I oh my god I think it's cuz of the boats I was gonna say I don't understand.
That's it.
Come over here.
I've had enough.
Get over here.
I'm done with you.
There you go.
It's five.
If I just keep shooting them, they'll die.
I'm not even going fast.
How am I doing proper damage?
I'm just on a boat!
That's right, leave the boat.
Boom!
Oh my god, if that boat explodes, I'm fucked.
There we go.
I escaped the ambush.
They didn't say how they escaped the ambush.
The Ocean Man returns.
The sequel.
They thought they saw the last of Ocean Man.
But every five years, he returns to claim another victim.
What is that?
Jackie!
Jackie, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Don't worry, I got you, Jackie!
Oh, shit, that too, the last job.
You okay?
Fuck, fuck, man.
Oh, man.
That must be traumatizing.
Being buried alive seems really fucking scary.
Like, incredibly claustrophobic, too.
I thought I was gonna die like an animal, man.
Fucking, like a dog or something.
Come on, brother.
You're okay.
i got your back fuck
remember mr beast would actually do like um would actually put himself in these stunts but now he just pays other people to do of shit
i remember when mr beast used to use to put his own life in danger for money now he's just too rich so he pays other people to do his thing do stuff for content
i can't believe it even he started outsourcing yeah you see did like there was a famous video i mean he has a lot of bio videos but one of the first bio videos i watched from him was when he buried himself alive Now it's just Mr. Beast of Gladiator Games.
Now he just outsourced everything.
So what do you want to do now, Jackie?
Elections tomorrow.
We want to check out the build and make sure that Big Smile Lee isn't planning any surprises.
But we got some time to kill.
I don't know.
I almost bought it today, man.
Real.
I think I'm just going to go take a walk or something.
Oh, you got, like, kidnapped because you're by yourself.
It's cool.
I'll see you tomorrow or something.
Alright, I'll see you.
He just got fucking...
He almost died.
He's like, you know what?
I got kidnapped because I was alone.
Let me do that again real quick.
Boy, we gotta get this man a massage.
Don't worry, bro.
They treat me like a VIP there.
I'll get you the good shit.
Oh, go to bed.
I guess I'm EP now.
right at that point look he should crash by my place oh i should get that shrine but it's too far
where's my bed oh it's over there is that the closest house oh it is okay it has to be a cab nearby it's sleeping time me me me me me me all
right oh my god do i have to drive by myself god damn it Can't even fucking take an Uber in this way.
Every time I can't find a cab, I swear to God, it's because it's raining.
This is too real.
Cop job, truck recovery.
Hide Piper, wheels of furry.
Detour, lost, early grave.
Okay, there you go.
Go to bed.
Oh my God, there's a cab.
No, get back in!
No!
Oh my god, there's another cab!
God damn, I just missed two cabs.
That's no.
Don't leave.
I need my Uber.
Oh my god, bro.
That cab is so fucking fast.
Wait, is that an Uber?
No.
Look, look.
It's open for business.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'll make him stop.
There we go.
Sarah, I need him.
I need a ride real quick.
Sir, please.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
There you go.
It's so sensitive.
The cab hunter.
Yeah, not complaining now that I paid you.
That's right.
Yeah, I live here.
I have a confession.
Someone was like, it's not even that far.
I have Uber Eated.
Uber ate, or Uber eats a restaurant that was literally like six minutes away.
Walking distance.
I have done that before.
I am a part of the problem.
I have indeed, it was literally a six minute.
and walk away.
Wait, come and meet me.
I have something to show you.
Oh, what does Jackie have to show me?
Yeah, I do.
My favorite car.
Hey, you seems to be okay.
Not like someone stole his phone last time.
Where is it?
Oh, the election.
There you go.
Wait, how far is it?
I guess it's just so convenient.
like you know what you discover uber eats and like uber eats or grub hub or uber like you just can't stop it's just it's just so i can't go back i can't go back i don't want to driving for myself Wait, I could just hire someone else to do it for me?
Her door dash?
Jackie?
Fucking knew it.
Jackie, you fucking dumbass.
Jackie?
Oh!
Jackie!
Fuck!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Hello, Mr. Shen.
Or should I say, Officer Shen.
My name is Mr. Tom.
Perhaps you heard of me?
Fuck you!
I'm no cop.
Oh!
Your friend Jackie didn't think so.
You think a massage would fix it?
But then, I suspect you wouldn't have told him any.
Oh!
You must be a very dangerous man, Wei Shen.
Son of a bitch, I'll kill you.
Save your energy, Mr. Shen.
You'll need it.
The last cup I had in this chair lasted almost 48 hours.
Would you like to try for a new record?
I understand your personal reasons for doing this.
From my tattoos.
They're very expensive.
Before I'm done with you, you will confirm them.
And then you will die.
Oh!
That's what worries me, Wei.
You're one of them.
Oh god!
Their actual torture methods too.
Loyalty.
Discretion.
John would be disgraced.
How would they, how did they know I'm a cop?
Bro, I told them, I told them I was undercover.
That's why my car was a police car.
I was like, oh, they would never expect me to be a gang member if I have a police car.
How did they know?
Boy, when I was wearing that tactical uniform, when I was wearing that tactical uniform i'll just go to my local larp the police larping club you know i wanted to be in if i to order to like make sure i don't get arrested oh my god i have to crawl this is pathetic to make sure i don't get arrested i gotta be no one's like to be a cop you know it's a mystery yeah i was just playing airsoft too yeah sometimes we play airsoft every every friday
Okay, isn't there a guy like slowly watching me do all of this?
Oh god, this is so pathetic.
Yeah, I was good at sit.
How the fuck am I gonna survive?
Oh shit, that's how!
Looks like you're having light problems.
Want me to help you change the light bulb?
oh god i am definitely i definitely have blood loss right now i ain't feeling so good lights out
just a bit lightheaded right now
how long is he gonna pee for damn that's a long ass pee
Oh, no!
I did!
I thought!
Oh, no!
I didn't realize!
Oh!
I thought he would keep peeing.
He was a long-ass bee!
How is I supposed to know?
I thought it was just an infinite cutscene until he was done.
Well, I can't do anything but counters.
I'm too light-headed right now.
It's the only thing I can do.
I did it It's I thought it was unlimited.
I wonder if I was able to if I would have done like a
Special kill if I'd like if I actually press B
Oh there is wait if I bring him up to the toilet i see a table why would you have a table sign all right give me a sec okay i gotta take you somewhere it's very important oh wait is that fridge i want to check come over here i need to check if it's still there Why it's like this way?
Wait, he's still watching TV.
Do you see the other guy?
They're just...
He's just jamming on the TV?
No!
Not locked back in the door!
I'm so sad.
Here's Johnny.
They're really...
This was...
It is pretty.
Gotta check it.
There's asbestos in the drywall.
There you go.
I should have pressed B, guys.
I'm so sad.
Play through ruin.
Come on, get over here.
Get over here.
I gotta use you.
Looks like the elevator is out of order.
Alright, get over here.
Oh my god, what the fuck is this?
Alright, let's see.
I'm pretty sure I put him through the pull, right?
Oh!
Oh my god, yeah, you saw that?
Man.
Careful, you might have a...
Oh, it looks like you have it.
Oh, come on.
Let me pick you up.
I got the one right.
Oh, man, careful.
It looks like you might have a splitting headache right now.
Gotta get that checked out.
Oh, there's more.
Nice.
All right.
Get over here.
Oh.
Looks like I got a meal prep today.
Oh,
wait.
Is that fridge also a special one?
Hey, yeah.
Remember to clean your fridge.
That's fucking right.
All right.
Nice.
We did it.
Dinner.
Sir!
Wait, what?
We're still talking.
I killed all of them.
I wonder the body is still there.
Oh wait, no.
The elevator's closed down.
Where did these guys come from?
Oh, what were they doing in the closet?
Whoa.
It's like, damn, what were they doing in that closet?
Meep, thank you for the 10, give the chips, thank you, thank you.
There's seven minutes in heaven.
And for someone that just got tortured and, like, had holes drilled into their knees, this has to be the adrenaline right now.
I'm like, bro, I just had, like, I think I lost, like, 40% of my blood.
The adrenaline actually is going crazy right now.
out that's right get over here looks like we blew a fuse
you just broke a glass bottle all right that looks like something i can use what is that i don't barbecue season!
Did you want it?
Did you want it extra well done?
Or is there anything else?
I think that's everything.
That means you know what that means.
I'm just gonna throw you against.
Oh, I can't throw you off the building?
That seems so easy to do.
For one henchman extra crispy.
That sound seems so easy to do.
but they were having a barbecue
oh shit
oh my god there's too many people there's too many people that's it I'm bringing one out of the equation
okay give me a sec to the wall
that's right if all else fails I have the wall invisible walk.
Divide and conquer.
There we go.
Might as well break your leg, too.
Like, grab him!
Not if I grab you first.
Oh, shit.
Not him.
I can't grab him first, unfortunately.
It's alright.
I'll just kick him in the balls.
Even if you're ungravable, your balls are still vulnerable.
Doesn't mean I can't kick you in the balls right now.
Oh, wait.
Maybe you can just grab me.
there we go that's fucking right oh shit he can still grab oh no no no no no no no all right we'll just start kicking him his one weakness apparently is just ball kicks
there we go all right i got his one weakness wow father macy I like how they added hell to it, but he's just saying what's going on.
Oh.
Oh, no, it's stealth task.
Oh, what do you know?
Where the fuck do I go?
Didn't I get in and get past that?
Oh, my God.
He saw me, didn't he?
He saw me.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
I'm here.
He's still gonna grapple you.
Oh my god, he's still got it.
Bro, at that point, you could have just shot me.
Oh my god, wait, not now though.
I didn't mean...
Oh, my back!
I'm paralyzed!
I'm paralyzed now.
I got this.
Watch this.
Oh, shit.
shit it's okay i could take it i could take this that's why you can't predict this you can't shoot me man he shot me in the back it was like magneto sent that bullet fly that's right stealth
That's right.
Stealth mode.
There you go.
So stealthy.
Don't worry, don't never know.
I'm stealthy right now.
Don't never know.
A perfect stealth.
Alright, reload.
Oh shit, double kill, nice.
Oh shit, okay, I should stop taking that.
There you go.
One more shot, one bullet in a dream.
Okay, it was Ashley too.
Feel it!
Handgun is stronger, only because like, I can accurately shoot it.
Yeah, there you go.
Yep, I'm here.
He's like, I know you're here.
Yeah, there you are.
There we go.
Yeah, I mean, he wasn't wrong.
I was here.
Yeah, this is definitely faster.
They just line up their heads for me.
I think the last guy is like, wait, where is the last guy?
He's like, I know you're here.
I wasn't hiding.
All right, perfect shot.
That's what you know, I'm an FPS gamer.
Line it perfectly.
I know where it was.
Good cover, bro.
Wait, it is good cover.
Wait, that was good cover.
Headshot.
I didn't say wishhead.
The muscle memory.
What the fuck?
I'm like, where is the cover?
Yeah, that's definitely the cover.
Oh shit.
Why am I reloading in the open?
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
One guy left.
Oh wait, is he like...
Oh, I actually got like burns on him.
Yeah, I don't think they got the shot Actually Excuse me?
What is this made of?
What is this?
What is this made of titanium?
I'm like, why can't I shoot it?
And where I'm in the pool
I don't think he's having any kids today
Nice shot you think I got him Where's my gun can I just not pick up my gun back?
Oh, it's sauna time All right guys, I'll pick a one-liner from chat With a sauna animation kill.
This is a very special animation kill guys
there's a very special one who wants to have the honor this has to be a very special one
oh i like that one all right i like that all right there is a way i just got oh my god there's no way Oh my god, they're ungrabbable Oh, wait Nice No They can't do this to me Oh my god, they can't do this to me They actually can't I had the perfect I had the perfect dizziness
Wait, I could do this
How the fuck Oh, there it is How the fuck did that Stagger him Guys, I gotta stagger him!
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
No, you cannot do this to me.
You do not do this!
No!
No, you don't do this to me!
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
He won't let me grab him.
That's it.
No!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Why would they tempt me?
Such a good...
Such a good environmental kill!
How could they do this to me?
I'm so... I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
They baited me.
They baited me with such a cool animation kill.
My day is ruined.
Oh my god, I can grab him now.
Yo.
That's right.
It's getting a little steamy out here.
I suppose I should be impressed.
You defeating my men like that.
I am not.
Now.
What?
Where were we?
oh my god that's a big knife i see you've cut your way oh my god bro what the fuck he has a shot ass what the fuck does this game want me to do i got it oh my god oh it's good that's right watch this jump kick oh my god he just slashes me watch this jump kick oh i think he predicted it after like three tries but what predict a fourth jump kick that's right no he did it okay it's not fair you nearly have a nice
i like how he just calmly walks towards me too jump kick again oh jump kick into a counter surely you won't expect this a third time oh my god he actually countered it he actually countered it that's crazy
Oh my god, I'm a little fucked up right now.
It's okay.
Watch this
Wait, he's still oh, yeah, no, he's dead dead.
No, oh he is very dead.
Oh my god the watch this actually worked
Yeah, that works I'm sorry Jackie
Poor Jackie Fuck the election.
You did this, Lee.
And I'm coming for you.
Motherfucker.
I did not expect them to kill off, Jackie.
I legitimately did not expect it.
I thought we were gonna be bros for life!
I thought we were gonna go into the sunset on the boat!
And like...
Live with new identities and everything.
Everything I'm just gonna drive this car away.
Goodbye Oh,
no, we're gonna have our little bromance and everything I'm warning you here and now making anyone other than me the chairman's working the death You are an officer of the law way same as me Wait, we're supposed to be bros for life We don't need to bring her into this.
I like the way you think.
That's the attitude that makes us strong.
Loyalty.
Discretion.
Used to be more common.
I'm here for Miss Lily.
I take a huge hug on Big Smiley.
That's what worries me, Wei.
You're one of them.
Where you cross Pendry.
He's cutting you off.
Wait, yeah?
Want the rally exit?
Oh, oops.
You look after our people, okay?
Man, this big spot late, man.
This guy just fucking grabbed me at the fucking funeral.
Toss me up to 18k, man.
You show your true colors to that, brother.
Oh, God!
I'm sorry, please!
Please!
No, no, no!
Oh my god, the PDSC is kicking hard right now.
I must stop this once.
No matter what happens, Jackie, I won't leave you behind.
I always come back for you, Jackie.
I'm a best friend, man.
That means more than a boss, you know.
I always come back.
He was most loyal.
I know you have a personal stake here, but this cannot be of indebted.
We're cops.
There are rules.
It might be time for me to make a change.
Maybe going to business with me.
you made you can't win kill me and lee will simply wipe you out
oh god that's so stressful if only there was a place to release it thank you for the super chat sorry thank you thank you can't believe he's dead we're gonna open our own bow shop
A bow and massage therapy shop, two for one special.
Have a pork bun before your massage and a pork bun after.
All right, that's it.
That's it.
You were part of the problem.
That's actually pretty fucked up.
You did.
She was also in the...
Yo, just because she's a woman, I can't kill her.
She was also...
Oh, no!
No!
I don't think that girl is...
What do you mean?
She was there with them.
Yo, that's a mess.
Killed by association.
Alright, who's first?
So why was she hanging out with them, huh?
This is like...
there she was still there slashy slashy I'm just gonna slash I'm too mad no one liners tonight I lost I lost the pro of my life I said I treat her to him the next massage therapy but there will never be a next massage there will never be a next massage infiltrate the compound
yeah parkour
jesus this is a line here you go no gun can save you from a giant knife i don't need a gun all i have is big knife Okay, I should have bought a gun.
Okay, I didn't think there were 20 of them, okay?
I would have known that there would be 20 men in front of me.
I thought I would have consistent 1v1s.
Parry this.
I thought I could parry!
Alright, I'm so sad I gotta get rid of it.
I gave him a stupid gun.
It brings a knife to a gun, right?
Alright.
Now I just gotta give boring headshots now.
Alright, reload.
Doesn't feel the same.
The only joy I can get out of this are the nuts shots.
I think he's...
Oh my god.
Yeah, he's way too close.
Oh my god, don't worry, I'm fine here.
You can't shoot through this.
He's too stupid to realize that's also in cover.
Shoot his hand.
Oh my god, I can't shoot his arm.
Where am I?
Oh my god, TP me all the way back.
That's right.
Get an ass shot.
The wrong side, motherfucker.
Defeat thugs.
There's more?
Where are they?
Oh, they're right below me.
Okay, there you go.
That's fine, this one's easy.
I was like, where are the others?
Right here.
Come on.
Oh, you're so lucky.
You are so lucky.
It was perfectly aligned, too.
There you go.
I still got you in the nuts.
I still got it.
Can I shoot through this?
I think I can.
My shoulder!
Alright.
What?
Where am I supposed to go?
Like, down here.
Oh shit down here.
I don't know if this does anything.
Alright, last two are like over down there.
Fuck more!
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm too lazy.
I'll let the environment do my job.
Work smarter, not harder guys.
Okay, never mind.
Apparently this thing is unbreakable.
Never mind.
Get over here.
up why would they bait me like this
but he's still alive i shot like 20 bullets on you no this thing was just unbreakable for some fucking reason watch
how of course it breaks of course of course Oh, wait, he was innocent.
Oops.
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
They're running away.
There you go.
I saved you.
Oh, my God.
Just leave.
Still killed her?
Okay, that's on her.
That's on her.
That's not on me.
Like, how could she get caught again?
Sir.
Stop resisting.
How is that supposed to know she get caught again?
That's on her.
She should have kept running.
Oh my god.
Just leave.
Go.
Follow the hell of me thy name.
Why are you running back?
Wait, actually?
Give me a sec.
Okay, no, he's a criminal.
I should be allowed to shoot him Guys, no, okay.
No, I should be allowed to shoot him.
I
That's a crazy lie.
But can I just go straight to killing him?
Let me check.
I can't imagine.
No!
Wait, it was so close.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, I think I can't.
I might just focus fire him.
Easy.
I told you.
Just focus on him.
Okay, now we can focus on the other.
On your left.
There we go.
Easy.
Okay, they should just like give up.
I literally killed the boss.
They should have been like, I surrender.
The boss is dead.
You now work for me.
I'm the alpha here.
Look, I killed your boss.
I think you should know, you should think like, you know who I am.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
There's no cover.
Can I use the fishes?
Oh my god, if only...
Wait, what?
Oh my god, this is terrible cover.
I don't have cover!
Oh wait, here.
Guys, if I could, I'll do it for the last guy.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit!
Oh shit, he wasn't the last guy!
He wasn't the last guy!
Oh, I didn't kill him.
There we go.
I just didn't kill him.
Get phased.
Okay.
Surely this won't fuck me over, right?
I'm gonna kill you.
Oh boy, wow, there's a gun.
Oh!
Shit.
How?
Time to die, Lee.
That was three shells.
I saw my fish.
Yeah, there's no way I live, right?
Minus 5% for being clumsy?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I have blood loss.
I just got shot in the shoulder.
How the fuck?
I'm sorry.
Oh, take my license for being clumsy ever after taking it.
entire fucking shotgun pellet.
My life still?
Jesus Christ.
Oh, the salt in the wounds too.
Oh, the ocean in the wounds.
That's not good.
Why is there a gas station in the middle of the river?
You're pussy.
You're done.
Piece of fucking shit.
Fuck.
Oh!
How does it feel, Pig?
To know that your boss sold you out.
And you fucked your way.
Almost as bad as you fucked Jackie.
You were supposed to die with Winston.
Dog eyes blew that and that po guy tongue fucking worth a slung young Oh, he planned on this Fuck you Also, where the fuck are my cop friends?
They're all like useless But I know how to counter Oh my god, bro.
Oh my god.
This is so sad sad for me oh my god please I've lost 70% of my blood I shouldn't even be alive right now oh this is so sad look at look how weak my punches are he's like come I can back up.
I can still do it.
Oh
Got this
Okay My fucking punch
That's right I might be losing a lot of blood.
Oh my heart's beating so fast Oh, it's sad.
It's time.
Did anyone order some ice to go in their drink?
Ice, ice, baby.
Hey, easy their way.
This man is in my custody.
Yes, sir.
You okay?
Yeah.
Where's Pendrew?
He's up for promotion.
What?
Interpol?
He gets away with everything?
He ought to meet a big smiley.
Take it from me, Wei.
Whatever you heard, it won't matter.
The only voice they hear is Penrose.
You did what you came here to do.
Alright?
Let's get you cleaned up.
Oh my god!
He gets to go to Interpol?
The rich truly do get richer.
Yep, the fuck you mean get clean I need a blood transfusion right now.
I lost 70% of my blood
Bro, can anyone like dig out the fucking shotgun bullet out of my shoulder, too?
I knew I told you Superintendent Pendril Classic Hong Kong cop movies you're the one The British white guy who's in charge of the police is always dirty.
I can imagine all sorts of reasons.
I'm sure you will tell me.
I'm moving on to greener pastures, but not without taking care of some unfinished business with you and Sonny first.
We had a deal, did we not, Pendrel?
I gave you the three tigers.
It made your career.
And I let you and Sonny continue operating.
A sacrifice you were willing to make.
putting some away and with you gone.
I'll finish this once and for all.
The only difference between you and me is...
I know what I am.
Did he like put air into his infusion?
Jesus Christ.
Or like a judge
Poison you can also give an air bubble oh that that's it that is that easy I don't like just give they don't even give me a montage I he's just he's just in jail now Whatever I did I made Hong Kong a better place Bro, there was gang wars It was like I was like I clearly didn't enter for it.
How was that better?
We're open carry.
One of them.
You deserve to be handed over to Big Smile Lee.
Did I?
Well, Pedro, I guess everyone gets what he deserves.
There were shootouts in the streets.
You ready for life in prison?
What?
Because all your old buddies are going to be waiting for you.
I made sure they found out what you did to Uncle Poe.
That's a fucking death sentence.
I know where you can't I won't last a day in there That's the plan
Inspector officer I just wanted to say thanks for what?
It's me who should be helping me close cases do something I could feel good about hell for helping me stay sane my pleasure So what are you gonna do now?
Yeah, good luck surviving prison punk My job's over, but I don't really have anywhere else to go.
It's strange to say it after all that's happened, but Hong Kong kind of feels like home.
Yeah.
But which Hong Kong officer?
Oh!
And what about Wei Shen?
He proved himself to be loyal to me.
One way or the other.
And isn't that what really matters?
Leave him be.
Yes, I'm Jay.
Drive.
Wait, that's it?
Bro, and we never got a sleeping dog's true after?
Bro, that was the most obvious sequel, babe.
And like...
We never got a sequel?
We never
got a sequel!
That's so good!
The dogs are still sleeping.
I can't believe it.
Because it's like...
I guess it's like an open-ended ending.
Because we don't know if he's like...
If he still works...
If he wants to work with the triads or...
But he doesn't have Jackie anymore.
Like nothing ties him to the triad.
for Jackie.
So I feel like why would he continue to work with the Triads after that?
Oh, the studio shut down?
Oh, it's so sad.
I feel like the game did really well too.
It didn't do well?
I thought it did.
I had like good memories of like people talking about sleeping dogs.
Um, and a singular super chat.
Thank you.
He seems like he's going to be picking up soap.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I feel like...
Like, I don't know.
Because it's like...
I don't know.
I feel like he wouldn't lean towards the triads.
Only because, like, the only one that was, like, his anchor was Jackie.
And also, everybody knows he's a cop now.
So, it feels a little weird.
Unless they want him to be, like, their rat.
You know?
in the cop, like a dirty cop, but I also feel like Wei wouldn't be a dirty cop in general.
He did all of that for undercover.
Strike, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Thanks a bunch for playing this great game, but just notwithstanding.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I had such a fun time.
It was so cool.
I had a great time, like, exploring Hong Kong too, and it's, like, memory lane.
Mine is the turf wars and the...
The turf wars and the gunfights in the streets.
It really did feel like Hong Kong, other than the violent parts.
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When it got popular, it was already too late, from what I remember.
Yeah, minus the crime.
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Check out the another trailer.
see your sequel in the hand-to-hand combat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Now we'll never know why the dogs were sleeping.
Is there an after-credit scene?
Oh, yeah!
Wasn't there supposed to be a movie?
I remember.
I remember seeing the news about that.
They were planning on uh...
They were planning on making a movie for this they got canceled too that's so sad i can't believe got canceled as well i feel like maybe maybe if this game was released at a later time i don't know i don't know i don't know if this game was was too good for its time at like um was released too early for its time Or too late.
I don't know.
Because I feel like it was really good.
So I don't know.
Like what they could have done.
To like.
Increase the popularity at the time.
There was a lot of similar games back then.
That's true.
There's like.
Was it Watchdogs?
Watchdogs?
Assassin's Creed.
I think GTA 5.
Yeah.
Was it released around GTA 5 too?
That might have been it.
maybe it was like after GTA 5 it would have done a lot better Saints Row oh I forgot about Saints Row yeah there was like Saints Row as well and they released this like maybe like maybe in 2015 or some shit or 2016 I think maybe it would have done a lot better
at that time the genre was way too crowded yeah now nowadays it's harder to make like open world like gta like games now not a lot of games do it very well i think this was really well done it was very like huge throwback to um to like classic um classic hong kong police oh my god three $150,000.
That's crazy.
Wait, I got a plainclothes cop outfit.
What does that look like?
It was a great experience.
I had a fun time playing us.
I'm so happy to find me able to play Sleeping Dogs.
Oh, is it this one?
Detective Chen?
This is a really shout cop for me.
It just looks like my funeral.
Wait, it's literally...
I'm literally wearing the same shirt and pants.
I'm I'm wearing it's interchangeable it's interchangeable to to my funeral outfit all right let's see this is the perfect outfit to go get a massage all right one last massage for the ride oh my god am I wearing socks with my sandals oh my god wait no okay it's just They're my sneakers.
Men's wardrobe, be like.
That's true.
I feel like, okay, for me, I feel like, um, you're very limited.
If you watch for male VTubers, they're very limited to, like, uh, well, actually might need a, which one is, oh, it has to be here.
There's a K-bar here.
You're very limited to, like, what kind of outfits you can get.
All right, one last massage.
Is this literally suit or, like, not suit?
I feel like suit, sweater, or t-shirt.
One more for the road.
Alright, and a pork bun.
One last pork bun and massage for the road.
Hello, can I...
Wait.
I gotta move a little bit.
He won't sell me the pork bun because I'm like, blocking the street.
No, sir, please!
He didn't like what I did.
I get iron tire.
Where the fuck is that?
Oh, get tire tire.
We have a...
What the fuck?
I stole this car.
What?
No!
It doesn't want to sell it before you get fired from pork buns.
It's the last pork bun for the road, though.
Please.
It's the last one.
How would I become a whole man?
Also, how the fuck do I get to the massage?
Where is it?
It's like locked up secretly.
I think it's because there's a cop here.
By bumping into him.
I don't think he'd like that.
What if I...
What's the closest ocean?
Wait, it's inside the mall?
Wait, there's a mall?
I don't know, there's a K bar here.
Oh, it's inside the K.
Oh, it's inside the K bar!
I forgot about the K-bar.
How could I...
Ever since...
How could I forget about the K-bar?
That's where I met the love of my life.
My fifth girlfriend.
One
last...
One last massage.
Hello.
Hey, stranger.
Want to help me work out my fingers?
Sure, why not?
I've got something special for you today.
Oh.
One last massage.
Come again soon.
Nice.
The real final mission.
Patreus, do you think of a super chat?
Thank you.
I'm sorry, Doki.
You have to play Yakuza to scratch that itch.
people with a bowling ball though uh self-win thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you can lock the car with a mini gun and electric wave attack wheel of fury side quest thank you the super chat thank you thank you thank you i think this is a good way to end the sleeping dog series a true happy ending
thank you all for watching guys i hope you guys enjoyed my sleeping dogs play through i had a very fun time playing this game it truly was like uh i just like how all like the like you could tell like people made this game i lived in either lived in hong kong or like had experience living in hong kong because like a lot of them were really like you know called back to what was like living there except for the turf wars and the triad part
the environment and like just like the the script as well it was very like Hong Kong coded yeah um but thank you all for coming I hope you got thank you sorry I'm like a teenage boy right now thank you all for watching I hope y'all had fun watching the series um my voice is dying now but tomorrow we do have a sponsored stream tomorrow um so I will be streaming on Sunday on twitch by the way it'll be sunday on twitch uh at i believe i believe 5 p.m pst i would confirm that with my manager after the stream but i hope you all enjoy series i think like i might take monday and tuesday off just because my voice is dying a little bit so i gotta take care of my voice because now i'm like you can tell that it's getting very scratchy now um because i did a lot of Oh,
double streams here, I realize.
Anyway, I always have a great time streaming with you guys, for you guys.
And, and why?
Sorry, my brain is fried now.
I always love streaming for you guys, and I hope you guys always enjoy watching me.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!